i've seen my abs be photoshopped and i i
was okay with it i use it for
inspiration for myself cause i'm like i
know my abs did not look like that at
that time so i'm gonna get in the gym
because they could look like that if i
did a little bit of work
[Music]
instagram models are real models
three
two
one
go
if you're posting photos of yourself
you're feeling cute girl you are a model
you know i definitely think so too if if
you're enjoying yourself and promoting
yourself naturally and you know being
who you want to be and making money off
it most times then get your coin girl
yeah okay
i think also the idea that something has
to be monetized for it to be legitimate
it's also
damaging you know what i mean because
for a long time in my career i was
self-producing things right and then
people people started reaching out to me
oh do you want to book this campaign
today it starts yeah
right i definitely respect what you said
um but it was funny because it like
literally tinged at my standard
so i was actually i started in atlanta
when i was going to college doing
modeling and i remember i met this
beautiful model and she was like i
didn't consider myself a model until it
affected my bank accounts and literally
that became my goal was like i would not
call myself a model until it affected my
bank account our instagram models
fashion models
i would probably be way over there but
our instagram models models yes because
whether you're modeling on top of cars
or you're modeling clothes or you just
do hands or you just do shoes i mean
give credit where credits do like a lot
of instagram models are not only
modeling they are styling they are doing
their makeup they are self-producing
they are shooting like that is a job
the thing that only frustrates me at
least because i'm not industry standards
for like being a fashion model i feel
like a lot of people would see me and
maybe think i'm an instagram model and
it's like no actually like
i pay for my entire life with modeling i
feel like people think less of what i do
or don't expect that i could be a
professional model
because of that existence of of
instagram models i was just thinking of
the whole
industry and just paying homage in
respect to folks that have like gone
hard going to casting calls that like
have built their portfolio have gotten
rejection from agencies and things like
that versus like someone who's just on
instagram i'm not saying it's a bad
thing but like being on instagram
posting pretty pictures and then getting
a bunch of likes
i have hot take prompts which are
prompts that are submitted by our
audience assumptions that they make
about models
models secretly judge fat people
i feel kind of liberated being a plus
size model because i'm not expected to
be anything i'm not does not mean that i
haven't had my fair share of extremely
phatphobic situations that i've had on
set all the 2000s we grew up on tabloids
when a celebrity would gain weight
especially a woman it'd be like oh look
at her in a bikini like oh she's gone
off the rails so i do believe probably
some models do have these
microaggressions but it's also
the system's fault it's not specific to
models i think it's everyone yeah
models encourage eating disorders
i don't think models at all encourage
eating disorders i think what people
perceive that models may do in order to
stay skinny but that's on perception and
it's the perception of it that needs to
change some of these models do promote
going down to a size zero and these
agents our agencies are ex-models we
used to watch tyra banks america's next
top model she was extremely severely
rude to those girls
like takara the biggest girl on there
and she was a size 12 she used to go
down her throat in the specific
reference that you were talking about i
think that this woman was
critiquing the models
from her experience and what she knew
the industry was she knew
for this young girl who has no name is
not signed you have to fit the clothes
or you don't work at the time at the
time i disagree that models encourage
eating disorders on other people i think
that models encourage eating disorders
within themselves oh definitely so i
wouldn't say that they
are encouraging directly but i would say
as to naomi campbell and tyra banks how
they were saying if you're not going to
fit the clothes you can't get work so is
that you should be losing weight or
should the clothes be made bigger
modeling promotes unhealthy beauty
standards
three
two
one
go
i think the la industry for modeling is
becoming a little more inclusive
but i think in the high fashion sense
awful it's kind of promoted for most
girls to have like an eating disorder or
stick to this calorie restraint so
for me
we are the people and we as the people
are society and society dictates what
the industry does and i think that's the
reason why it's become more inclusive of
everybody so it's important that we
don't blame our industries for what they
do as much as we hold ourselves
accountable for what we accept so when
we spend our dollars with this industry
we're actually voting every single time
so a lot of it was prompted because we
weren't seeing equal representation so
people were stopping spending their
money so they had to reorganize and
recreate and now they started being more
inclusive it's us as society that
dictates what's going to be promoted so
if it's an unhealthy standard it's
coming from us not the industries
i do think that
the reality is we are
more affected by what we see than we
really
understand like we internalize a lot of
the things that we see a lot of people
my age are starting to get botox and
fillers and instagram people are or
instagram influencers excuse me are um
getting a lot of
artificial work done to their faces
to look a certain way and i think that
putting someone that is super young or
that has like no wrinkles or that has
like no acne in your face every single
day and you see that representation
every single day when you get a up you
think it's not normal yeah when you have
a double chin you think it's not normal
and those things are not the truth it's
not necessarily the model modeling
industry i think we saw started to see a
shift when the kardashians like exploded
because
paris hilton size 0 size 2 was like the
look and then here comes kim and here
comes the family and
big butts right and like we went from a
a system of like
stick thin being like the beauty
standard to now like
hourglass curves when so many people of
other ethnicities have always had this
but have been rejected for having these
things and that led us to a whole
facetune photoshop era where everybody
wants to get a bbl and get um breast
implants and have like a cinch waist and
like big butt and all of these fillers
and like i don't think it's the modeling
industry as a whole that's promoting
that look more still social media and
like these influencers and these reality
show people that are like botox and
filled to like the brim to me i'm like
do what you want like i i have no hate
for anyone that wants to do what they
want with their body like you have that
autonomy you do you but i think the big
problem that we get at and i feel like
it is more problematic honestly in the
social media space at times because
they're claiming
that everything is natural they're
claiming you know oh i just worked out
and i got this body and it's like that
those what might seem like little white
lies to them has have impacted our
entire generation of these young women
especially it's important that
that we realize we have that autonomy
too like i've done a photo shoot and
been edited to kingdom come and like i
never had an ounce of cellulite on my
ass and that's just not the case and we
need more people seeing those normal
aspects like you said acne wrinkles like
people have that you know
i am okay with being photoshopped
three
two
one
go
[Music]
i completely agree with being
photoshopped well i don't think it's
healthy for the public image
i'd do this for me i model for myself
you know and i've seen my abs be
photoshopped and i was okay with it
because i was like it paints a really
great picture you know i i use it for
inspiration for myself because i'm like
i know my abs did not look like that at
that time so i'm gonna go get in the gym
so i can get my abs to look like that
because they could look like that if i
did a little bit of work um so
on my end i'm completely fine with it
again it's about the client and the
story they're trying to tell and it's
this like
unattainable kind of guy sometimes and
it's like yeah but i think it's more so
again it's important that people realize
that that's the story that's being
portrayed that's not always reality so
i was on somewhat disagree because it
feels wrong but last week i had a shoe
and i was shooting bikini and i had a
zit below my butt and i was like so like
guys can we just like photoshop this out
because like it's it's enough that my
butt's on a website but my butt with is
it i don't i don't know so i hear that i
mean like people like us are probably
more likely to be airbrushed
significantly more than most people and
i don't want anyone that's going to
change my body shape if it means me
being the brave one and kind of being
uncomfortable with the way i look in
some pictures whether it be belly rolls
in my stretch marks or my cellulite like
i think that that's a necessary evil at
least for me in terms of like what i
want to see change in this industry and
like see that positive impact as what
you were saying like a zit or something
and i struggle with
dark circles and stuff like that i want
clear skin and that's the image i want
for myself so i would be completely fine
if someone touches up my dark circles or
you know makes my legs longer in like a
fish eye bubble lens or something you
know in that sword but to take away from
my stretch marks to take away from you
know my stomach i don't want to perceive
something that's not me because that's
that's not my brand when you're on
camera like how you may look to yourself
or like on
in
the mirror doesn't always translate on
camera
and then it's like wait my pores are
that big or like my eyes look that
sunken or she's right on that though
with the lens is getting better in the
industry it's portraying us even harsher
because they'll pick up like wrinkles
you didn't even personally see on your
face and so yeah a little touch-up kind
of cool with that
i have insecurities about my body
three
two
one
go
i've done a lot of work on myself like i
i used to hate myself and i've done that
work to like come on the other side and
recognize that i'm beautiful but i think
the only reason i say somewhat agree is
that it's impossible to be in this
industry and not
be hyper aware of of the things that are
you know that you should change or maybe
should alter or like oh this girl is
working more than i do
what is you know like
what's better about her body than mine
and like and that's just in my
pure moments of weakness and not
weakness but in my pure human moments
let's say in the real world like from
walking down the street as a pedestrian
right like my body is like whatever but
like in our industry and what we do we
think well will i book a job if i have
this extra like five pounds on me you
know what i mean are like would i book a
job if i was a little bit taller so i
think that like body image issues
that i already had were kind of
magnified when i stepped into this
so i'm liking a great place so i
actually probably should be on like
somewhat disagree um
again my my only holdback was like i'm
from the south i like everything a
little bit thicker so including myself
that is always a self-conscious part i
would love to put on some extra muscle
one day which i just know it comes but i
do sacrifice it for being in the
industry at this time but i completely
accept it i still think it looks good
it's not my ideal self but it is still a
self that i am happy with so i think
i'm just i'm still going through fully
accepting myself i still think about my
body and myself every day but i'm in a
good place i'm definitely better than
what i used to be and more accepting
like you know what i am big i am curve
and i look good you know i i have the
courage
i have the courage i have like the
genocide quan you know like we i have
everything that anybody else has and for
you to be confident as well and when you
know it that confident like oozes out
and you can feel that when someone's
energy as well so right
and that is officially a wrap
and we wanted to gift you guys some
jubilee merch
oh my gosh
[Music]
you